come back round problem number seven
let's see they do a triangle here let me
draw a triangle here as well trying the
triangle drawing a triangle okay so then
let's see a drop it's kind of altitude
like that like that this is a height H
this is perpendicular X Y Z they say in
the triangle above XZ is 67 of H so this
right here is 67 CH the length of the
altitude right H is linked to the object
what is the area in terms of H well area
is equal to one-half base times height
right and what's the base one-half times
the base well the base is 67 h 67 sh and
then the height is h h so times H so
this equals let's see this too it comes
with 1 this becomes a three so I get 37
times H squared which is choice B they
wrote as 3h squared over seven but we
know that that is the same thing so that
is choice B next problem problem number
eight if a and B are positive integers
and they say a to the one-half power
times B to the one-third power to the
sixth power is equal to 44 32 what is a
times B a times B is equal to one well
let's see what we hear I just try to use
exponent rules and play around with this
as best as I can so if I raise a product
of two numbers that have exponents and I
raised it to an exponent that's like
raising each of these to the exponent so
that's like this is the same thing as a
to the one-half to the sixth times B to
the one-third to the sixth and then when
you raise something to an exponent then
you raise that to an exponent you just
multiply the exponents
so that's the same thing as a to the
what's one half x 6 that's a cubed and
what's one-third x 6 well that's be
that's to write one third times 6 is 2
so that's a cubed times B squared is
equal to 4 32 and then we could even
write this as we could write this as a
times a squared times B squared is equal
to 4 32 and then this we can write as a
times a B squared I'm just playing
around i actually don't know if this is
going to get me to the problem is equal
to 4 32 so this is interesting we want
to figure out what a B is so if we can
divide this expression by some number
some some integer and get a perfect
square then we're essentially done so
what happens is let's let's just try / 2
what's this / to you divide it by 2 you
get 2 16 is 216 a perfect square let's
see what is a what is 16 times see I
forget 16 x 16 6 times 6 is 30 is 30 69
then 160 no that's 256 that's 256 so
that's not just 256 let's see 14 x 14
that might be it 14 x 14 4 times 4 is 16
1 times 4 is 4 is 50 60 140 that's 196
so it's no 216 isn't a perfect square
but what if we let me erase all of this
let me erase this as you can see I don't
do these problems at a time I do them in
real time for your benefit okay I don't
even know if I'm going down the right
route this is I'm just taking it cold
like you will when you when you're in
the mix of things so let's see what
other numbers are there let me make sure
my pen is all right so let's see it is
this divisible by 3 s what happens when
three goes into 432 432 into three
it's 100 remainder 313 goes into its 4
times 4 times 3 is 12 12 oh look at that
that's a perfect square so we could
write this that's equal to 3 times 144
so a bee could be 12 right how do I know
a bee could be 12 well if a if we see it
a is equal to 3 if we set a is equal to
3 if a is equal to three then a B
squared then this whole term is going to
be equal to 1 44 and if this whole term
is 144 then we know that a B is equal to
12 and that's choice B you know you
could have done it the other way around
you could have actually looked at the
choices and tried to work backwards you
know I kind of fumbled a little bit
trying to figure out well how can I
write for 32 as the product of a perfect
square and some other number and you
could have tried each of the choices
squared them and see and try to see if
they actually went into 4 32 and and
also met the other constraints that a
and B have to be positive integers that
are different etc etc and of course if a
is if a is 3 and a B is 12 then of
course B is for but we didn't have to
know that all right next problem invert
colors okay problem number 9 what is the
greatest three-digit number that has a
factor of 10 that has a factor of 10
what is the greatest three-digit integer
that has a factor of 10 oh okay that has
10 as one of its factors I for some
reason when i read that it just didn't
register in my brain so i'm looking for
the so first of all what when they say
three digit integers so this is you know
we're essentially saying any number so
let's say x is our integer so it has to
be less than or greater than or equal to
100 it has to be less than 999 and we
essentially want some number in this
range that has 10 as a factor well what
do we know about things that have 10 is
a factor they end in 0 right 10
20 30 40 50 all of these depth and in 0
so what's the largest number that's less
than this number that ends in 0 well 990
and that's our answer problem number 10
maybe I don't have to clear this I'm
just do it right here problem number 10
a recipe for chili for 20 people
requires four pounds of beans so 20
people requires four pounds at this rate
how many pounds of beans are required to
make chili for 150 people so we can make
a ratio 20 is to 150 as four pounds is
2x all right I just say you know I'm
just kind of whatever fact i have to
multiply 20 x to get to 150 have to
multiply the same factor to get 2x and i
just set up a ratio and if we cross
multiply we get 20 times X right 20
times X is equal to 4 x 150 what's four
times 150 it's 600 divide both sides by
2600 / 20 is 30 we need 30 pounds of
beans if we're going to do it for 150
people the next problem problem number
11 I'll switch colors when the positive
even integer n n is positive and even is
increased by fifty percent of itself so
plus fifty percent of itself the result
is between 10 and 20 so it's between 10
and 20 so 10 is less than n plus point 5
n which is less than 20 alright that's
what we know what is one possible value
for n so let's do a couple of things one
we can simplify this what's 1 n plus 2.5
n that's 1.5 in 1.5 n and that's
actually I'm going to write as a
fraction that's three halves n is
greater than 10 which is less than 20
and what we could do this is
inequality right so we can multiply
every term of this inequality by
two-thirds right so two-thirds times 10
is less than two-thirds times 3 halves n
which is less than 20 times two-thirds
so here we get 20 over 3 is less than
this cancels out let n which is less
than 40 over 3 and 20 / 3 this is like
you know six point something some things
a little less than 7 is less than n
which is less than 40 / 3 this is this
is like 13 points something something so
you have to pick at any number between
essentially 7 and 13 so n 7 is less than
or equal to n which is less than or
equal to 13 any number you pick between
that range would work so 10 would be a
good number to write down and a very
easy way of doing that problem is just
trying out 10 and seeing if it worked
out and it would have worked out anyway
have 10 seconds left so I'll see you in
the next video